just keep it running all right that girl
nearly got us killed you gotta admit she
did hold her own back there you ain't
gonna make it oh oh I ain't gonna hang
it here I miss that is you'd be amazed
at how many cars still got gas I don't
appreciate thanks brah look bill uh
about your buddy back there uh that's a
tough deal we square we r square and get
the [ __ ] out of my town
like an [ __ ] oh we chop them off back
at his town for the cards be three cool
actually that's when I was an apple on
this guy
okay look at all nature Ivan like the
cut all days hey what happened to
sleeping okay I know it doesn't look
like it but this here is not a bad read
only one problem right there to be
continued hey Claire scenario did you
get that uh Maggie bills I mean all this
stuff was just lying there [ __ ] at that
what else did you get well here let's
make you all nostalgic you know that is
actually before my time I schatten that
is winter though can't forget wow this
song so [ __ ] old Oh better than
nothing oh I'm sure your friend will be
missing this tonight oh you got the big
gay meeting but it's got some
interesting photos ya le that ain't for
kids whoa how how the hell could even
walk around with that thing get rid of
that hold your horses i want to see what
all the fuss is about [ __ ] Barney's all
stuck together oh my god I'm just
[ __ ] with you Oh
baby can now pittsburgh was [ __ ] us
I feel it's got a father but you know
what this isn't that bad what you try to
get up sleep good like entire a shat no
perfect know what screwed they can't dis
thakkar Hauge hit
oh [ __ ] well on to get some gas dude
there's no one around them when they're
coming after
easy me is a trap are we gonna help him
no it's her seatbelt Oh Lily what about
the guy he ain't even hurt
huh hey sighs okay okay then get help
quick bot and dick suck whoo holy [ __ ]
no not without coming first Oh a cat
long with these guys catch your breath
we're leaving oh shut out stay down [ __ ]
the gangster wait to town why's my thick
not alota God oh [ __ ] jeez where Oh
oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
over the bus don't I have
oh [ __ ] well got him Shep I need this
guy where is he Darius you [ __ ]
[ __ ] good good getting a [ __ ] and
dogs dead oh [ __ ] yeah you like it suck
my deck oh [ __ ] [ __ ] that one hurt I'm
so bad at shooting shot him right in the
[ __ ] face who else is here all right
I think that's the last of them you okay
yeah I guess so
I guess something you're out here I
guess huh you know the drill look around
see if there's anything we can use I
guess I'll Senor Senor I guess huh I
guess huh that's how you're gonna talk
that that I gotta talk you know it just
okay I SAR I guess huh when I says what
is this [ __ ] that I got a lot of good
[ __ ] out there is that alley thank you
good good get Ken got cat got okay good
anything they know shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] I'd be better way out in this yeah
now that gel uh-huh here I got the
[ __ ] controllers gone nuts okay
anything good here any good lit up how's
that I was fulda whatever was Oh [ __ ]
bottles bottle in this game what is that
so that is as a brick how that's the
most to help me I'm do I look like a a
motor guy like em I like a carpenter or
something like it why do I have a brick
and mortar shop like this I suppose that
help man yeah okay like what I need is
some lube go where I [ __ ]
yeah but first let me let check the area
but i think i'm just not gonna loot to
[ __ ] Oh God God yeah you're pretty cool
early I like the way you're saying hey I
check that like didn't they burst and
then I China like we go that way what at
this place it's a lot of [ __ ] here that
is this back ya [ __ ] ancient computers
says I'm fall fall took a joke it's an
Italian fall
okay well here we go
but I got a [ __ ] her yeah we might
got to spell out cargo seeping get a
proper boy some pretty gnarly stuff in
here Ellie what is that large look what
is that I got a good hermit oh hello got
to say you John the partay okay well
think with her head [ __ ] whene'er to
start gathering supplies what is that
Jeff a bomb
is like a torture chamber we're like my
[ __ ] face fat bondage I just had my
body's you're stabbing things go and I
love it Taurus manifest says okay okay
okay epic I've had nothing okay what do
you want [ __ ] hunters see this killer
band us that is a lot of people that
didn't mean again I should have turned a
damn truck around you lived barely come
on let's get out of your hair lay like a
bear there's no no what about the ambush
I've been on both sides and listening
damn looks like that isn't yes take it
however you want there's people here I
could sniff him
they surely no one here why would they
give me like this much space like free
room yes this is where the [ __ ] sleep
and slept mmhmm mmm wine very nice help
get okay no actually got a [ __ ] 10 oh
they're looking pretty good [ __ ] ones
outside right
little matter just keep moving okay what
is this map how it's ambush map
bostrom final cars here distractions ah
Matt stars
let's do this you know actually like the
shoddy so club capacity well I spring
this [ __ ] up high bay very lads read
okay oh [ __ ] [ __ ] the range up [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] it I can tell that's a music or
that's [ __ ] like a clock in distance
okay all right here's the bridge that's
our way out of here yeah I can have a
car they'll eat slow down wait for me
what right here how about you let me go
first and keep your voice down okay yeah
are you pretty cool I got a myth that
much like I was our only spider-sense us
real quick okay
take this plant okay thank ya it's all
this who's leaving all these [ __ ]
behind I'm whistling good something else
he and drive me crazy with ya now you're
like you many vets spider sent y'all
quick okay so I gettin hurts but open
spaces early I think I found another one
of them comics you've been reading can't
get hazed this patch okay right weird I
was kind of freaky eyelids open space I
thing what [ __ ] attack yeah now what
happened now we need to get the auger
something
he melt out of his car it's too hot
and went out here Oh shuttle Kelly get
down you got an entire block and [ __ ]
nothing oh [ __ ] about to hit you like
the [ __ ] was that a dog that you jump
down hell are those guys they put to be
here on the highway ain't nothing here
keep going I shot that [ __ ] in the face
okay here's the plan I run up to them my
[ __ ] shooting with the shoddy out
jealous [ __ ]
man I should take I [ __ ] gut with
that little gun I thought there's three
guys oh well anything good here what is
this paean beezness steak work the comb
noise here one over here hey okay what
the [ __ ] is this how'd you get over
there already that bridge looks pretty
far we'll get there whoa strange seeing
a checkpoint with no soldiers this is
what most owns look like this place has
been abandoned for a while now why I
don't care what that controller shake is
I keep doing it makes a noise should I
see what he's doing but the bus our
rations okay what's this campus are rat
ions okay is that lost he'll know I lost
hit tote ragtag okay why wouldn't they
give them their food sometimes they ran
out most times it is held onto it never
happened in Boston trust me it happened
all the time okay
you'll die before we starve [ __ ] like
some noise you bet it is here hunters
yeah me too just keep it down while
we're going to this area thank you
uncheck or are they
he got away do not sense them are they
Cat Cat Cat hey he just literally saved
be careful I see him [ __ ]
where is he
where the [ __ ] is a
right act 3 oh [ __ ] when I was a gun Oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm getting [ __ ] up
[ __ ] [ __ ] kill this [ __ ] [ __ ] I
thought there was like two guys but I
guess has my where the [ __ ] the other
guy
how many guys are here
Circa in here
yeah i'm just going to cap on it so it's
easier
it's kind of out of here but no well
meeting on this level oh [ __ ] wait till
this guy shows up and I grabbed him oh
yeah mother [ __ ]
yeah you like that [ __ ] huh [ __ ] is a
lot of them [ __ ] runnin [ __ ] I [ __ ]
died but you know I didn't got like a I
didn't go like a [ __ ] okay that's
that's all i gotta say i didn't go out
like a [ __ ]
okay shut I'll get this [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] I gotta right oh [ __ ] I had to
hide a little bit
come on come on cut
okay we're just sneaking through her
hair we're just sneaking out of here oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] we got to keep going we got
to get gone oh [ __ ]
oh sure
where is he where is he
can't see [ __ ]
[ __ ] there's a lot of people on this
mission
ah
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] there's definitely people
over there let me heal up thanks
poster damn close I got him into the
universe and back excuse me and Aaron
survive okay yes okay Jesus I got a
[ __ ] heal how's that now there's a
lot of good stuff downstairs but I
didn't get a good luck you know okay
more bricks now with us yeah that was
[ __ ] insane and then a hand of it I
just took out like a [ __ ] hole where
else okay
okay where I supposed to [ __ ] go oh
no long it would take the stealth out of
you think through here wait did I not
need to go through this [ __ ] our
house I like actually don't know where I
just go my guess is i have to go the
other side of this [ __ ] not this wall
but if I can't go through here than I
definitely yeah I got to go all the way
through here I think okay [ __ ] it I'll
try it just see where i could go they
always know how to make her look
innocent oh here's exit
okay looks safe up Anna's s J's another
30 soldier set what's a guy a desperate
enough they'll do just about anything
the people that rose up they're the ones
we've been fighting here it'll be my bet
Jesus time to [ __ ] savages let's see
where this leads us watch yourself on
these drops yeah watch yourself before
you wreck yourself take fast night yeah
how close am I to get 15 your juices
swept in swing that weapon soy how it's
that that's bad let's say here let's see
here
I'll chef
there's more well two guys okay I got
all right I don't think they saw us oh
there's our bridge nice i wouldst I'll i
think who's keypad come on I can't make
that job if you get me up there I can
move that plank so do that anything
either like floats
ah I beautiful how's the noise oh sure
mm-hmm hey just got another one now
graphics greatness hey [ __ ] sucks that
sword with this unique it is one hand
right wait here single petal you know
will come through the hotel come on get
on is this the hotel hey I guess that is
the hotel hey singer that way let that
plague like they did okay wow this is I
smell smell like [ __ ] shet idea that
but let me just check this real quick if
it could be stuff here
check check what the [ __ ] is this it's a
weird that there's all this room on the
side oh good stuff good stuff take test
I hit that get back yeah stash know I
like to view this it goes down tonight
we're gonna take the hn checkpoint valet
exercise the Regal apartments okay that
ooh somebody got [ __ ] weird there
somebody got weird shut man the place is
[ __ ] gone to [ __ ] that's varies like
a [ __ ] another thought yeah words
all run did you go to coffee shops a lot
I did all the time and what would you
get yes just coffee okay that's that's
awesome i chose that coffee house ah
poor ali well you could have seen that
where I like I was I would have been so
funny oh yeah we're gone the hotel okay
do you think those hunters are gone
we're going to find out it's clear Ali
come on down Oh fancy huh never say to a
place like this okay before I don't want
to shoot it um I guess we're gonna end
this episode here it's out for her Amish
Oh